Oh
yay Oh
Canada
today from the lands of Canada's
prognosticator won Willie he's honored
nay he's absolutely thrilled to welcome
you all to his town now help us us we
are his town criers yes it's time to
wake up Willie if you
please as we ask God's blessings upon
Canada all together let's wake up Willie
wake up Wily wake up Willie wake up
Willie wake up Willie let's hear it
there he is everybody W up Willie wake
up welcome won
Willie now the man is going to lean in
he's going to talk to Willie going to
communicate we'll just kind of watch and
be quiet and
listen oh 5 wow that was so quick 3 2 1
no Shadow which
means early spring early spring early
spring that's what we got
yeah
as town criers for Willie we're proud to
shout no Shadow he saw no sun came out
so once again the crier Bell did ring
yes Willie predicts I repeat it's an
early
spring now return to your homes with a
sense of great joy bring out the
bicycles and Springtime toys now Willie
will remain on the STR on the stage
waiting for spring safe trip home and oh
yes God saved the
king